Udacitask1.0 was a hit, but
list making applications are evolving,
and so has Udacitask.
You now want Udacitask 2.0 to support
a variety of item types, text, quotes,
lengths, tasks,
calendar events, you name it.
For this project you are going to focus
on completing a prototype of Udacitask
2.0 that will support three item types,
tasks, events, and links.
But you want to keep in mind that
Udacitask 2.0 could support 10 or
20 item types some day,
organization is key.
Keeping your code scalable and
organized gets much harder as
your projects get more complex.
So it's best to anticipate
these challenges early on.
In this project you will refactor and
expand on Udacitask with modules,
while using Gems and Bundler to improve
your desk task style and functionality.